Do you hear that?
What’s going on?
That’s a good question.
There’s got to be an explanation.
Know we oughtta do?
Yes, sir.
You wanted to make history, so maybe this is your chance.
There are things that you can feel and not describe.
Over the course of a law-man’s life, he comes to understand
why he was chosen.
Owwww
Where are you taking me?
A new world.
Hi, fellas.
I’ll go in three…
Two…
One.
Launch!
Oh my God, it’s so great, isn’t it?
It is gorgeous up there!
TELL ME!
Oh no, it’s a song.
This is my Beach Boys song.
Wouldn’t it be nice?
Boom!
You’re the girl with the deaf family, and you sing?
Here they come.
You’re it for me.
I feel the same way.
When she sleeps, she turns into a wolf.
I’m begging you to come back to me.
The world deserves to see this.
I do believe you have just had a breakthrough.
We fight for freedom.
Only we can shorten the darkness.
Hey, it’s a story.
We’ve been working really well together.
This is unbelievable!
So, what do you do?
I teach fifth grade.
Shut up, I love you.
I think we’ve all had enough of this amuse-bouche.
Time to move onto the main course.